let me make way for some royalty here
Ernie Johnson Turner Sports studio host
and he's got a book unscripted the
unpredictable moments that make Mike
extraordinary nominated for 2019 Sports
Emmy outstanding sports personality
please say hello to Ernie this lady at
US Bank Stadium through these
Minneapolis fog this morning you look
like you're ready to go on here I've got
to I've got responsibilities today oh
you do yes okay Coaches vs cancer
luncheon oh nice you're the host gonna
be right over there yeah I'm gonna emcee
that and so that's happening after I get
down here nice nice socks you got life
is too short to wear boring so yeah like
again let's see the socks well we're
ready to play basketball yeah
all right we're working on it I just
have a little Under Armour song okay
yeah just a little basketball sorry KC
game breaks up why are you man I'm great
I am I'm great and you what's the ring
you got on that is um the Georgia Sports
Hall of Fame I was inducted this year my
dad was inducted nine years ago and so
we're kind of it's very special to me I
wear that and I can't help but think
about him and it's very cool did you
ever think about doing something
different mmm when you were growing up
yeah you know what it was baseball
player first cuz you know my my dad
played and so I grew up in that kind of
a family and so that was the goal was to
be a major league baseball player and
I've told this story a million times so
you can laugh at it if you if you care
to know we're good at fake laughter okay
this will be good then just practice so
I so I walked on at the University of
Georgia as a freshman and made the team
was told to walk off it's true so that's
as far as that went and I actually
thought I'd be an English teacher and a
baseball coach if if baseball didn't
work out and you can still do that
yeah but but then I started trying this
you know working at the campus radio
station at Georgia lousier first paying
job first paying job was
WAG QQ 105 in Athens where I was the
news and sports director hmm and I had
and this is after a summer internship at
W laq in Rome Georgia country radio
station killing it
oh I was man how much you remember your
paycheck oh no it was just so it was
something which was great and viateur
what was stupid about it is I wanted to
work at a real radio station and so I
went and interviewed at Q 105 and I
didn't even have an audition tape with
me I had worked it at the campus radio
station but I showed up there and the
guy says well let me here with you let
me hear you I was like I don't have an
air check well why do you how do you
expect us to hire a lot I mean I've been
doing this and he said rocky we'll take
a shot when did you know you were good
that's that's such an uncomfortable
question because I knew for a long time
when I was bad that's for sure
no I know you know I was I listened to
those those old w u OG the first
assignment I had was hockey corner and
this is this is 1975
it's w u OG hockey corner I'm Ernie
Johnson and I was explaining the game of
hockey because it was relatively new to
the city city of Atlanta the game is
played on a rink of frozen ice they use
a hard rubber puck it's it and it oh man
I found that reel-to-reel one day and I
popped it on and I was like how did I
ever stay in this why I should be an
English teacher of a baseball coach but
no I think I think you get better at
what you do when you're surrounded with
good people and I've always I've always
had that but I think I realized it when
I got to ESPN and like there was a
moment that that it was real when I
wasn't nervous and I was being myself
for the first time yeah I think well I
know exactly what you're talking about
and I think I think preparation is is
behind all that when you're when you're
prepared and you never feel like he
looked at the basket could break tonight
and they could throw it to me for a
half-hour and I could do it you know and
I think I think that happened when I
probably when I was at Turner when I
when I was at the the ABC affiliate in
Atlanta there were still those times
where
when the red light went on it was just
like and you and you fumbled for just a
second then and you felt like you felt
like everybody at home was going Martha
come over here boy just kid trying to
read the moon it's pretty funny and so
but but I think I think a turnery it got
to the point where if you had a mistake
you just kind of played it off I grew up
watching Johnny Carson Johnny Carson was
the guy I watched every night when I was
growing up and I loved the way he you
know a lot of times he was funnier when
things were not going well
he played things off so well and I think
that's always been something that I said
look that's it's not the end of the
world if you screw up a lie and I tell
that to my broadcast students if you
make a mistake on the mistake and
there's nothing wrong with making fun of
yourself because get ahead of it yeah
because I'm gonna take that weapon away
from you if you make a mistake and I say
this to the Danna and you make a mistake
then you just say I made a mistake
because then people I think identify
with you that you're willing to say that
and we move on yeah exactly and I think
it takes a while to get through that
because the first few times you're on
the air and you do and make a mistake
you feel like oh that must have that
must have taken a week and a half for me
to finally correct that and and then you
looked at it back so it really wasn't
that bad and the iana treated it way too
way too seriously well the first time I
was ever on the air at CNN first time
the microphone didn't work so I'm there
I'm killing it like I'm looking at that
camera and I'm killing it and it's you
know looking like that and then all of a
sudden you have one of the anchors Luda
or I'm not Lou Dobbs I forgot who waters
I think his name was so you can see his
hand reaching and then I got through
fast forward to a Sunday night working
doing SportsCenter I open the show I
don't have my microphone on I'm late the
Obermann and I'm just one of these
things obermann's hand comes over
what's his microphone on my tie and then
I get done and I go Keith and then he
goes he motions back to God
have to give him his microphone right
yeah but you know we embraced it and as
I move on the way it the way it is these
days you know you if if somebody does
something like that or shows up without
a microphone we would stop the show
right now we will stop the show and make
fun of the guy for the next five minutes
like I mean if Charles sits down and
he's got a spot on his tie because he
spilled some dinner I mean there are
times where we'll come on and it'll just
be a tight shot of the tie that will
hold back well it's haven't explained
how the spill got there whereas at a
time it was never let something that
happened on TV or tell him tell him he's
got a spot on his tie but we live for
that now and do I have a second for a
story yeah because when you start going
down this road of remembering things
like that and I can remember I'm
anchoring the weekend sports at WSB in
Atlantic and when you do the weekend
sports you are just working so hard
you're editing you're trying to get the
show seven minutes you know all prepared
I hadn't put hadn't paid any attention
to the news so I get on the sports and
we're doing British Open highlights and
Greg Norman is hitting a shot out of
stuff like like it's this high and I say
so here's a Greg Norman doing its best
Marlon Perkins and you know ba ba bla we
go to commercial break
news anchor looks at me says what are
you doing I said it's Greg Norman is
that the British Open those faces we did
the Marlon Perkins obit in the second
second what have been nice to know that
before I before I went down that road
yeah maybe you should have watched the
news when they were doing the Marlin
Perkins open you remember your first
show with Mark Lee anything stand down
uh yeah I and I can remember he and
Kenny coming out for halftime again as
they always do about 30 seconds before
we go on the air and Charles asking
Kenny he said what are you gonna say
when we talk about this you know I don't
even remember the topic Ken he says
you'll find out and that basically set
the tone for the rest of the for the
next 20 years
is that we were not going to sit down at
second segment we're talking about the
Clippers and then you know so you be
ready with something you'd be ready with
something that's like whatever you got
in the saddlebag the saviour's show oh
you won't believe how many times I say
that because these guys will start
getting into something you know on the
set in a commercial break and how can
you say don't go there yeah this sounds
like it will really be good so let's
wait and and that's the way it's been
for years I remember doing that with Rob
Dibble when I was doing my radio show we
have two former nasty boy and he would
always have these moments during
commercial break you go yeah I remember
when we stole this beer truck we were in
minor stop stop stop
right there I don't want to hear anymore
then he goes yeah I dated this girl at
Applebee's and she had black hold right
there and then I would say dibs
you know you date when you were in the
minors he goes he and then he looks at
me like you're already known what the
story is and then I had to teach him
tell the story as if I didn't know it
and then he gave the great story goes I
dated this girl who's so pretty
had horrible teeth so I made sure that I
didn't tell her any funny jokes so he
said I I really liked her but I just
didn't want her to smile because she had
bad teeth aren't there there there are
certainly stories that you will not get
into on the air right yeah and and I
mean because we all know that stuff so I
mean yeah there are things that I will
not go into with Shaq and Kenny and
Chuck even though I know the story yes
because you know what line you can cross
and what would not and you brought some
lines there yeah there have been a few
times there have been lines he is Ernie
Johnson Congrats on the in Sports Emmy
nomination thank you I appreciate it and
to you guys too for the show and an hour
inside the NBA was nominated too and I
think I think we we feel the same way
that you feel when it's I mean it's
everybody who's involved in the show
it's all the studio folks it's all the
production folks it's everybody takes
real pride in that because everybody is
part of that but to be candid we're not
rude
for you guys I know okay I mean I just
think just like it's every man every
show for themselves Oh without question
I hope you guys win you do yeah okay
Ernie's the bigger man here we're all on
the family III it would be great because
you're right we'll have some reflected
glory in your victory because we're in
the same family we actually go to we
have a loser's bar that we go to cuz I
lose every year to Costas
you know I feel like I've been I feel
like Patrick Ewing or you know Stockton
him alone you're not gonna win a title
during the Jordan era and that's the
Kostis era so but you you got one like I
think we both stole one from toasters
yeah yeah no it's good we'll see but I
think it's always cool just to you know
look at the list and say that's nice
okay no I'm past that I'm past that he's
the great Ernie Johnson nominated for
semi outstanding sports personality
studio hose it's so it's not a pleasure
to be nominated no not anymore
no it's a pleasure to win Thank You
Ernie
great to see about pleasure for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience channel 239
on Direct TV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]